[Musique]
les bases d'impôts annoncées dans le
budget Gérard mardi sont loin de faire
l'unanimité plusieurs se demandent si vu
le contexte économique actuel la carte
n'aurait pas dû mettre sa promesse sur
la glace pour investir davantage dans
les services publics les municipalités
sont particulièrement et satisfaite face
à un budget qui ne répond pas selon les
maires à la crise du logement qui frappe
toutes les régions du Québec
on a une liste d'attente de 24000
ménages à Montréal seulement qui
attendent un logement social la crise du
logement c'est pas un slogan je tiens à
le dire
c'est du monde c'est des vraies
histoires humaines qu'on entend chaque
jour
[Musique]
vous êtes le ministre d'habitation du
Québec merci d'être avec nous merci
bonjour monsieur Thibault
vous avez entendu les critiques des
municipalités cette semaine qui était
pas contente du peu de fonds réservés au
logement social dans le budget de votre
collègue Gérard qu'est-ce que vous leur
dites
écoutez je dis que il y a à nouveau un
milliard qui est injecté pour
l'habitation dans le budget de cette
semaine un 650 millions qui pour la
brique pour construire et 350 millions
qui de l'aide à la personne qui
s'appelle le programme de supplément ou
loyer et il y a un 2000 d'ailleurs il y
a 2000 unités de
subventions au loyer additionnelles qui
ont été qui ont été octroyés dans le
cadre de budgeti donc c'est le logement
social c'est vraiment la combinaison des
deux peu importe le nom du programme
c'est une subvention à la brique et une
subvention à la personne et c'est encore
ce que le budget le budget prévoit cette
année ça avance pas très vite il y a
beaucoup de besoins il y a pas beaucoup
de villes de loyer abordables de
disponible présentement il y a
énormément de demandes vous dites quoi
aux gens qui sont à la maison qui
regardent ça ce matin qui se disent moi
j'en ai besoin d'un de ces loyers là il
est où mon loyer effectivement
je pense que vous posez la bonne
question on parle beaucoup de chiffres
mais il y a des gens qui attendent
d'avoir un toit puis
personnellement ça situation là me
touche et je veux accélérer les choses
pour qu'on arrête de s'embourber dans
les chiffres puis qu'on livre les unités
promises alors là ce qu'il faut c'est
que ça sorte l'argent est là il faut
livrer puis il faut livrer aussi avec en
étant responsable et ce sont des données
publics il faut garder en tête les
personnes vulnérables à qui il faut
livrer ça et aussi il faut garder en
tête les payeurs de taxes qui
s'attendent à ce qu'on lit ça à
l'intérieur de budget qui sont
raisonnables et bien gérés entre des
budgets raisonnables et les énormes
besoins qui sont loin et qui sont là
comment on fait pour trouver pour faire
la part des choses
on est un peu on est un peu victime du
fait là que il y a bon dans les
dernières 15 dernières années tous cette
écosystème là
était pas était pas efficient je dirais
bon on va dire
les gens vont dire parce qu'il manquait
d'argent mais c'est un peu la peau lui
là quand un projet immobilier dure 4 5 6
ans un moment donné il coûte plus cher
que s'il y avait été faite de manière
très efficace alors là on va changer la
donne et puis il y a une part là qui
revient au gouvernement du Québec la
Société d'habitation du Québec c'est une
grosse machine c'est un gros paquebot
puis là je vous dirais que on est en
train de le faire
le faire bifurquer là et de s'en aller
dans la bonne direction pour que cette
société là joue le rôle qu'elle devrait
agir oui et être le leader la locomotive
de tout ce processus à terme là vous
vous voulez que ça se construise en
combien de temps un logement au Québec
dans le nouveau programme là qu'on a mis
de l'avant on prévoit des délais qui
sont autour de deux ans
c'est peut-être optimiste là deux ans
deux ans et demi il faut que ça sorte
plus vite parce que le temps c'est de
l'argent en immobilier c'est encore
c'est encore plus vrai que dans d'autres
dans d'autres secteurs si le secteur
privé est capable de faire ça et il
tient les délais les cordons de la
bourse serrés pour que ça avance je vois
pas pourquoi dans l'écosystème
communautaire ou public on peut pas
s'imposer au temps de rigueur parce que
sinon si c'est vous et moi là c'est tout
le monde qui qui paye pour ça est-ce que
c'est l'écosystème communautaire au
public qui est sclérosée qui a pas que
c'est assez livré la marchandise c'est
de la faute
écoutez je veux pas dire c'est pas la
faute d'une seule d'une seule personne
ou d'un seul groupe je pense que c'est
l'ensemble de l'oeuvre qui au cours des
dernières années a manqué d'amour et
puis là on est en train de changer les
choses je vais vous donner je vais vous
donner plusieurs exemples mais
premièrement il y a les programmes on
avait un programme qui le fameux
programme Accès logique selon tout le
monde a parlé ouais c'est ça ce
programme là peut-être qu'au début pas
peut-être il a livré beaucoup d'unités
ça a bien fonctionné au début mais je
vous dirais que dans les 15 dernières
années le fait qu'il y a aucun délai
prévu là-dedans
il y avait pas d'obligation de déposer
des projets selon les besoins d'une
municipalité donc tu as des projets qui
se développaient municipalités pas
courantes municipalité point intéressée
par ce projet-là voudrait plutôt en
soutenir un autre alors c'était pas
attaché là puis même chose pour d'autres
projets qui touchent des clientèles plus
vulnérables qui doivent être attachés
avec les ministères de la santé service
sociaux ben là aussi le projet part donc
une subvention qui est donnée pour la
brique mais l'autre volet du financement
était pas était pas attaché alors dans
le nouveau programme d'habitation
abordable du Québec on vient on garde le
meilleur d'accès logis puis on vient
corriger c'est lacunes là pour s'assurer
que c'est pas premier arrivé premier
servi que les projets qui vont aller de
l'avant c'est les projets qui sont prêts
est-ce qu'on peut en voir est-ce que
vous envoyez la fin de ce problème là
vous connaissez les besoins vous êtes
familière avec vous vous avez été
courtier immobilière longtemps est-ce
qu'on envoie la fin de cette situation
là est-ce qu'on peut penser à un moment
donné on se dit problème et presque
réglé
écoutez selon selon les analyses
économiques
l'écart va se résorber et puis je parle
pas juste de logement social ou
abordable je vous parle crise du
logement l'écart va se résorber là au
fil des sept prochaines années ça veut
pas dire qui faille attendre que ça se
résorbe et rien faire
le gouvernement un rôle en matière de
logement social en matière de logement
social principalement abordable aussi
mais moi je rencontre justement je vous
le mentionnez je suis dans le secteur de
l'immobilier commercial je connais tous
les joueurs depuis que je suis en poste
je rencontre tout le monde puis les gens
lèvent la main pour aider alors je vous
dis dans les prochaines semaines et moi
vous allez voir il y a des des belles
choses qui seront qui seront
communiquées pour pour aider à régler à
régler la crise puis on est en train de
travailler fort sur ça
de faire le point j'espère l'année
prochaine merci infiniment d'avoir été
des nôtres merci merci monsieur Thibault
ça me fait plaisir